welcome everybody to family
we have got the whole freaking family
here
this is the family's extravaganza
sponsored by magic spoon
feels
and mint mobile and upstart so thank you
to them today we have a very special
episode we are doing families views yep
and we're going to win not an ip
conflict by the way because there's an s
at the end of both words families feud
steve harvey don't come after me
um
so it's going to be very fun and
exciting i'm excited so let's let's do a
brief uh introduction to our contestants
today uh on my right we have my brother
sean my older brother by two and a half
years sean
round of applause would you like to say
uh use the microphone or the mic right
up to your mouth there yeah uh sean what
would you like to say to the people out
there
um hi
wow
fantastic
a man
sean how's it been for you you're a high
school teacher and people often say
because we have a resemblance to each
other people have to say
and also the last name so people say are
you related to ethan klein you get that
a lot yeah i mean i'll get that even
when someone just hears me like i was
over your house and uh elizabeth was
like you sound just like your brother
wow how about that
so how was it teaching students who were
like
um well your brother is like obviously a
massive celebrity so how does that
affect your professional life
um
i mean
it kind of is a perk because like the
students feel like celebrities by proxy
they're more respectful you think yeah
because they're like oh mr klein's cool
because his brother's cool oh that's a
good thing that is fantastic so there
you go
exactly do you but i do feel like you're
cool in your own way do you feel like
you know you are sean klein and you are
cool in your own right do you have maybe
like hey where's my respect
no i'm i'm good i'm good with my
anonymity anonymity well we're getting
rid of that today here so
[Laughter]
well thank you sean klein my older
brother
my dad as everybody knows it's me
a short king we like to call him here
i'm taller today
what did we do to achieve a bigger
height i bought one of those medieval
torture devices the rack and i've been
doing like 10 minutes every day on the
rack oh really 10 minutes every day i'm
three quarters of a millimeter taller
abs fantastic you know just be damned
you know i've actually seen there's
surgeries that are popular now where
they can extend their leg like they do
some kind of surgery on their shins
and they can add like three or four
inches it looks very bad for you though
i'll just say that yeah it's definitely
pain so if that's something you're
interested in
not that concerned about it honestly so
i'm good okay you're sure king you own
you own it smash that like button
wow
my ventriloquist act yes smash that like
button is there anything you want to say
to the people watching today
uh
your mother has a working watch now as
promised right everybody's wondering
it was nice having a watch to look at
everybody was on the edge of their seat
waiting for that watch update so we
appreciate that
and i wanted to
thank michelle again by name the young
lady who worked at milwaukee baseball
stadium who thanked me for standing up
for ushers
and helping them deflate beachbody okay
here we go you're not an usher
okay my dad's referring to how when he
would take us to baseball games he would
grab the beach balls and stab them and
then the whole everyone would boo me it
would boo me my family well i'm with him
i'm do you understand when i'm a kid
people are booing my dad they don't even
know that you're with him oh please what
are you saying what am i just all over
twitter at the dodger game by myself
no
no you're not an usher that's not your
job okay they're being paid to be the
bad guy you're doing it for free go
ahead john no dad's definitely the
baseball fun grinch like definitely
like anti-wave too
yeah we talked about this on the show
i'm curious to get shawn's input and you
just you uh just this my sister jess
we'll get to you but feel free to chime
in
um
sean how did you feel
at a dodger game when my dad when our
dad
he's mine and yours
was in was stabbing beach balls and not
allowing us to stand for the wave
i was kind of embarrassed thank you were
you really yeah is that really
surprising
well it's humiliating
hope you enjoyed your last documentary
he already promised the tickets
but you're not going
he won't do the
if a beach ball comes by i will stab it
and if the wave happens i will yell
people to stop thank you thank you
you're welcome you're welcome there you
go that's dad's user agreement
[Applause]
first of all this is my uh sister my
much older sister jessica well not much
older i don't want to i'm not trying to
lay it on thick there but but she is 10
years older than me
so
oh nine and a half okay let's be
specific here jessica how does it feel
to be here today a member of family's
feuds and s at the end of each word to
differentiate it not an ip conflict um
i'm super excited to be here
um
you're kind of like a secret member of
the family right a lot of people don't
know about you
secret yeah maybe i've uh i've done
pretty well
hiding out in the 805
and uh yeah under the radar is there
anything you want to say to the people
out there uh i'd like to make a shout
out to my husband who is currently in
the hospital
what yeah what do you want to explain
what happened um he's a fan of the show
by the way so he will see this yeah
brian is a big fan
and uh was
did come here today and then we pulled
up
and he had a kidney stone attack and had
to be taken away by ambulance yes so
yeah a little more drama and excitement
that we had planned for today but um
there it is brian shout out to brian and
we hope you feel better
and ella
and eleanor yeah ella yes definitely
shout out to ella i know she probably
won't watch this who's not currently
suffering from a not currently suffering
from kidney stones and probably won't
watch this
she's playing minecraft
that's my uh that's that's my niece yes
okay how did you feel going to dodger
games with my dad do you have a similar
experiences i just want to get
everybody's to chime in here uh maybe
i'm alone i know everybody's going to
jump on me for this because i'm the uh
no i don't okay i was like never so wild
that i would like stab a beach ball to
take it out of circulation but as
somebody who has actually taken
a
beach ball to the head i can tell you oh
god forbid a beach ball hit you in the
head
as nearly as light as air
object okay next time we're gonna get an
inflatable beach ball and i'm gonna
spike it into your head could we get a
beach ball please do we have a beach
ball i mean aside from the beach ball
thing it does kind of annoy me because
when people are you know when the ball's
going around sometimes you're missing
plays and if you're actually there to
watch the baseball game are you really
condoning dad's stabbing
no taking weapons out if at a baseball
game not yeah you know not that was
pre-9 11 however yeah yeah
however i i mean
although my own personal 9 11 i would
say i mean you have to watch the beach
ball if it's in your area some idiot is
gonna hit it at you and i won't stand up
for the wave but i'll you know
you're conforming you're not happy
you're not excited but you're conforming
you got a microphone would we call that
conforming i guess i mean yes i'm just
like whatever get out of my way i'm
trying to watch the game okay so you so
it seems
like i'm not as traumatized as you seem
to be so for so what i've noticed here
is that the further away from my dad in
age
how dramatic it becomes
i see he's he's gotten to you he's
poisoned your brain yours a little less
and mine not at all
so that's what i'm that's how i'm
understanding this all right well i
think also there's a correlation between
who is most similar to me in their
sports
habits addictions i think it's all
related and jessica
just a little bit ahead of sean jessica
is more hardcore than sean is no
question it sounds pretty hard i think i
think it's more of an understanding of
the people around you it's like i mean
it's a baseball game it's long and
boring
i mean
wrong like okay all right there there
are points in baseball game that are
exciting and i'll go to the baseball
game but like bro there can be large
stretches and a lot of people gary klein
if you take him to another game
we're done
all right we're done well i don't care
you have to admit this season definitely
like there's lots
where nothing happens
i just went to
the boston yankees game that's like a
huge matchup right the eighth inning was
incredibly exciting it was a lot of fun
but the two hours before that prime
beach ball time prime b maybe you just
don't understand baseball all right well
guys let's not get too deep into
baseball here today we are here to play
a game
um of course the pregnant queen elo is
with us today as a member of our family
how are you this is your first time on
families
nice to see you how are you feeling
looking cool i'm a fan of the show
thank you thanks for having me thank you
it's our pleasure
welcome welcome thank you funny so
before we get to the show we're going to
be playing classic families feuds
with the surveys the buzzing it's all
going down here today and to make it
interesting we are putting up cash
prizes that i actually haven't thought
about until now
i knew i wanted to do a cash prize but i
didn't see but i didn't think how much
so what what should we do for the cash
prize let's say
we're playing four rounds
so let's say each
each
uh
okay this is good every round the
winning team gets 500 bucks what
oh now is this individually or as a
group as a group
as a girl i like your thinking i mean
you know we got to ask the questions
that seems good so the the winner
winning team potentially gets two
thousand dollars to share
okay
all right
all right give me a break here i'm not
made a model everyone's really gonna try
now yeah
i just want to put something on the line
all right but before we do obviously we
need to um
discuss a few issues where they put my
phone here excuse me thank you very much
this is your phone
squishy the fridge
did it go underneath the it's under your
leg
holy [ __ ]
you know my mom wants to go on about
butterflies guys she wants to do a whole
my mom goes to me she says listen i'm
she's ready to do a spin-off show
she's like i want my own spin-off show
just to talk about butterflies i was
like okay you know let's tone it down a
little bit
my mom's like uh big-timing me she's
ready for her own spin-off show i
canceled against that just fyi well she
can pitch it to me but i was just like
well okay frasier
we're a comedy channel yeah well you
know you could be funny on the show yeah
she goes i talk about the butterflies
and you'd be funny
yeah she she pitched it to us and i was
like wait so is ethan on the episode and
she was like no she goes you happy if
you want it's the donation she's on
[Music]
she's ready to leave me in the dust no
no no it's the bigger better thing
that's not going to know not going to
her head at all
you are the butterfly queen the
undisputed butterfly queen you sent what
looks like 20 videos
oh no oh we did want to give an update
the girl on omegle the girls whose
birthday it was she tragically lost her
father to cancer right we sent our
thousand dollar gift certificate to
american eagle i think it was and it was
received so the evil right the eagle
literally has landed right we shot her
out what was her name again
gosh i don't remember i believe it was
molly oh you're right that's right it
was molly yep
shout out happy birthday
happy birthday happy belated
so um
i mean
what are these videos you i think it's
just videos of butterflies well i had i
mean i wrote a whole thing what about
butterflies yeah
this isn't the butterfly show that's
what you think
well okay go ahead let's let's get a
taste let's get a taste of what you have
i mean we do have like a whole show
planned but let's do the butterfly thing
for a minute well she's she's ready to
read it's full double-sided yeah
plus the print is big is it really about
butter
yeah yeah do you have a name for this uh
she's very serious about this
no
no i really you didn't know about mom's
butterfly uh
she's actually
how did you feel through the what's up
conversations about it butterflies did
you know she bought a cabin in the woods
and she's going off the grid
you know i do feel like though with her
butterflies i noticed them more often
close to the mouth close to the mouth
dan came zipping in
that scared shredder thank you dan i'm
sorry shredder
well yeah give it give us give us your
butterfly uh your well should i should i
just do the small amount
with dan with the because this mor
yesterday morning one of my
butterflies just was born and we i took
videos of it okay actually happening so
damn can put that he'll overlay that as
we're talking now people are watching
the butterfly
be born right now okay so what do you
want is this the video on screen yeah
just do it in position
oh no i can't see it do it just do it in
post
with peace and love of course with peace
and love okay all right
all right so this is i'm gonna i'm gonna
just go for it
okay okay i might stop you
ah
okay so butterflies for centuries have
been migrating to this one particular
forest
should i talk and okay
[Laughter]
it's called the biosphere reserve
and it's located between the state of
michoacan and the state of mexico
and in the reserve there's there's
forests
or it's one big forest but there's uh a
giant i think mom should i just brought
this encyclopedia in with her to read
off of there wasn't enough information
in the encyclopedia
you guys
people are interested in this have you
not read the comments
okay go ahead
for the people okay so in this biosphere
okay there's two
two particular types of trees one is
called a pine oak and the other one
don't laugh at me gary it's called the
the uh
oil mill fur okay
and imagine my mom this is perfect she
can have a hut and a butterfly field
she's going to be totally feral and
building bombs in her hut
can we make this a combination between
the gong show and family
[Laughter]
no forget it forget it no respect
no respect let's be honest forget it
okay i'm sorry you're gonna get super
roasted ethan just by the way
last week there was a lot of anger about
not letting donna finish her butterfly
story well i'm just going to see him in
trouble then
you're not going to try it go ahead i'm
just going to sit here silently for as
long as possible while mom reads six
pages of butterfly notes and we all sit
here peacefully and listen go ahead mom
i'm interested donna i'm interested
i'll stop it baby you dressed up just to
impress my parents and it worked it
really worked go ahead okay
so the the the oil ml
fur
is now
down to two percent of its population
that's how bad things are the oil amount
yes yes anyway um
you know dad and i lived in in ajijic
which is in mexico for six years
and uh we met a lot of people and one of
our friends leo who dad talked to today
still oh my god
okay i digress anyways he has a cousin
who has a b and b
in mishawakan and a lot are you still
not digressing you're talking about your
cousin's your friend's cousin's b b
this isn't even on the notes yet this
isn't even on the note she said six
pages see i told you she should have
brought the encyclopedia okay well
there's a lot of people that come to
these being bees that tourists and they
come to see these butterflies and it's a
big part of their income
you know so you want to keep the you
know the reserve
anyway okay never mind so butterflies
travel about 2 800 miles to get to this
forest they do it every year they go
from canada from the united states and
most butterflies fly between 50 to 100
miles
every day
and one of them was actually that you
can tape your butterfly on the wings
which i haven't done yet but i'm i'm
going to start doing anyways one of them
which is
it's a little tiny square and it says
where the butterfly came from and then
when they find it how long do i let this
go on
before people say i'm not a jerk she's
in the first paragraph is this is this
isn't this only the one okay so the
lights are the center of the country no
no no let's not ask questions i'm not
asking questions no this is not that's
the question
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah so
monarch butterflies you guys tell me
here i'm gonna tell you abu this is on
you since you're such a kiss ass you
tell me ab when i can end this okay i
move on okay so ab go ahead it's on you
now
go ahead mom
donna go ahead queen do your thing thank
you oh my god you're so so butterfly
butterflies live
live between two to six weeks
and to get where they're going it takes
five generations
and the last generation is the largest
of all of the butterflies that are born
and they actually live eight to nine
months
but they have such trial and
tribulations they have the lowest
survival rate that's why there's so many
that that um are actually born
okay
so they they leave
they leave
in august that's why one of the things
we were talking about when you buy
certain native plants because they die
back
every part of the united states they
have a native plant and they die back
and it's can we just suppose people to
read on wikipedia about butterflies and
stuff okay let me get down to the chase
okay like i i did
to two twenty thousand acres of of
forests
have been lost annually because of
deforesting
okay that's tragic they're cutting them
down for illegal mining illegal logging
and illegal plantations
and um
the the uh
the the cartel is behind most of this
stuff
we're gonna stop them for sure and it's
it's a big problem
you know what 80
of our of our
it's funny that of all the things the
cartel is doing this is probably the
worst
[Laughter]
you guys
yeah exactly so we need to intervene
immediately yeah all that stuff is
really grown sean so 80 of the of the
marijuana has locally grown
tangent please go ahead god finish your
point go finish finishing please please
please we don't have time for this like
staring and [ __ ] please just continue go
go go you have sean's fault
okay
send a stamp self-addressed envelope to
donna and she will
you know what this is this is donna's
war on mexican cartels over the
butterflies
it's a big problem
did you know there's mass graves from
cartels killing like tons of people yes
i do and if you let me maybe talk about
it all right finish up
yeah ab go ahead
i feel like i'm gonna get [ __ ] for this
so i think maybe we should just uh
with peace and love move on but you i
would love to
i would love to hear about it after
though donna and i'm maybe you want to
talk about it baby unfortunately
ethan pays the bills
what if you guys scan the notes and make
a pdf out of it and tweet it
we can do that for you after okay well
and you know what we can frame it and
laminate it we can put it on the wall
okay but there's one thing we'll even
make a donation there's one thing
there's gotta be butterfly uh yeah oh
that would be good i'll donate your
winnings to the butterfly
okay her winnings oh you better talk
about it
well all right
um one thing i do want to share though
someone it was more butterflies
about aphids
av put the kaiba she already okay wait
that was on the butterflies though i
want to hear about aphids
all right
she's talking about aphids they're
predators of
no they're not predators they're just
pests a lot of people that are growing
the milkweed aphids are constantly
reproducing on the milkweed and it
interrupts the caterpillar and so they
wanted to know what how to deal with it
maybe
so what you do is if you have a potted
plant just bring it over to the hose and
gently maybe rinse it
donna can ladybugs take care of aphids
no and ladybugs will eat uh
butterflies
thank you yeah you can't and they were
taking their babies but they'll also
i
with peace and love i i like my job
it's not like that
okay all right let's move on let's move
on
oh shut up okay let's move on
now there's a few things let's talk to
you about uh before we get to the
mainstream i hope everyone gives you a
lot of crap
they definitely will what am i what i'm
the host of this show
it's my job to entertain that okay this
isn't off the rails i have to keep it on
the rails okay we have a brief set
amount of time okay my mom took 10-15
minutes just to get through one front
side of that six page report now guys we
brought the whole family out here please
just give don't crap on me what did i do
[Laughter]
okay let's move on thank you dear so um
did you guys hear about the matt damon
uh f word uh controversy yes
mom do you want to try to
tackle that
if if my family will well this i am
interested that's way more interesting
than
six pages of
butterfly notes oh come on
okay we're finding our page now all
right is this a different this is about
matt yes she always brings notes
so if you guys don't know matt damon
homework so tell what's the drama with
me okay so basically during a press
conference uh at uk's sunday times
he was there for uh his he was promoting
his movie on stillwater which is a
controversial movie in itself really why
because it kind of uh it mimics what
what happened with amanda knox members
she was that she was that
exchange student in italy and she was
accused of murdering one of her
uh call or one of her fellow students
and she was in she was in jail okay
anyways uh so that's what this
story is kind of you know mimicking
anyways so during the interview
uh matt damon sorta
gave himself up for using the word
should i say the word
definitely not okay the f word yeah a
homosexual slur a homosexual slur
and his daughter
at his daughter's urging she actually
wrote him a a treatise on on how the
word is
dangerous and this is the time uh
of the metoo movement which only goes to
show you that celebrities can act in
sense and sensitively
and uh they shouldn't be held as heroes
you know just because they play a part
of a good person that doesn't
necessarily make them who their
character is
um and
you know he's just been using that slur
and
um that's what it was all about pretty
pretty amazing how he self-reported let
me give the basic facts here
matt damon says he rece only recently
stopped using the f slur for homosexuals
after his
daughter his young daughter explained it
was unacceptable
uh damon told the uk times he had a very
long beautiful
uh trees from his daughter how the word
is dangerous
uh he said the druggery term for gay men
was commonly used when i was a kid well
that's true but i mean i'll like i mean
come on
i think that boat sailed a long time ago
she left uh she left the table angrily i
said come on that's a joke i say it in
the movie stuck on you which by the way
is a 20 year old movie
good movie i don't remember him dropping
an f-bomb in that one but uh anyways 20
years ago so he's holding on to that
and uh basically he says that um
it's just a joke and i don't know why it
is uh offensive but she convinced him
not to say
the uh f-bomb but everyone was kind of
tickled by the fact that matt damon in
2021 just learned he can't say that word
from his daughter thoughts everybody so
wait so he
he said oh so he said he won't say it
because she's upset
but
he still didn't
no he was saying he still doesn't think
it's offensive that she convinced him
why it's not
right
i'd like to comment on this being the
only uh gen xer on the panel here
uh boomer you mean boomer
no she's a gen xer are you kidding my
daughter don't give me that [ __ ]
so
i will say while using the f word is
super douchey okay not okay to use that
word oh
like the r word
you know it was just a funny word that
you said it the connotation was not to
be derogatory
towards
the group that is it is discriminating
against
and
you know times change but for somebody
who grew up and that's just part of the
vernacular
i mean i know people have made that
argument too with the n-word and i don't
agree with that oh well
i think that was never part of the color
no no i'm saying that people make that
argument i never really argue well like
southern people they're like oh i grew
up and everybody around me used it and
so they it's more like the
my point is that
um you're giving a pass
i mean you're giving him a uh empathy
it's more like the r word i think i mean
that usually well that's what i first
said the r word
what is the r word uh mentally
challenged
oh oh okay
you know the r word
i think less offensive than f word that
came out that kind of recently
everyone's like okay we shouldn't say
that anymore the f word kind of exited
stage a long time ago and we people
stopped saying that a long long long
time that is true i will also say though
in the uk
it's for cigarettes i know and it's sick
people do yeah but it's a different word
that's what people are calling somebody
a cigarette when they're no yeah i feel
like he was he should have known already
yeah especially he's in hollywood he
cruises in liberal circles
we kind of even have been through that
phase when people were still using it
jokingly but
yeah like you said it's been a while
yeah a while since a long time yeah i
will give it up to my mom by the way
when we were kids and that word was very
popular very common my mom was one of
the people would say don't say that
that's not don't ever say that word
that's not that's not right to use that
she was ahead of her time
she was ahead of her time
yeah
to go back to jessica's point like i do
understand what you're saying because it
was like
it was very common yeah and especially
if you like because he was a celebrity
from
goodwill hunting right back in the 90s
yeah exactly and if like when you're a
big celebrity like that like a lot of
people aren't going to tell you that
right because they don't you think he's
been cruising around saying the f word
this whole time and i think well i think
he's he's heard people like say you
supposed to do that but i think he think
amongst certain i think friends maybe
maybe someone that was like
close to him never gave him
i don't know
he's with media people i don't know yeah
but do you ever say in public that maybe
that's worse but i just know that
because that would so that he did know
regardless i love the idea of matt
cruising around his house calling his
daughters and his family members the f
word
which is clearly what was going on in
his house
that is pretty bad
all right and then the other uh well
that's about it matt damon so self
report yep
and ethan we have to uh go to break but
i will say you know the story by its
itself was like him
he was like listen i am confessing that
i just learned this is bad so in a way
he was trying to be like i my daughter
is great and she educated me it is funny
but uh do we cancel matt damon is this a
girl no no
we love matt
damon let's ask jimmy kimmel what he
thinks
i was just thinking that you're wrong
no it's just you can't make ref jimmy
kimball and matt damon have like a fake
rivalry on their show right that's a
boomer joke our audience are not
watching late night matt damon has a
show no no
i'm so happy yes matt damon has a show
about butterflies
all right let's go to a break and when
we come back it's time for the views
oh let's go to break and we'll come back
in my and what's her name
billy eyliss billy eyeless
billy island
eyeless
growing up cereal was everything to me
it was every meal it was delicious and i
just love eating cereal who doesn't well
when you grow up you gotta face the
facts cereal it's just not that healthy
it's got tons of sugar it's got tons of
carb and
it's not you can't eat it the same way
you used to as an adult and that's where
magic spoon comes in
they are reinventing cereal so that as
an adult you can enjoy the same
nostalgic beautiful tasty
experience of eating cereal but you're
gonna eat it in a healthy way here's
what i'm talking about they've got zero
grams of sugar
13 to 14 grams of protein and only four
net grams of carb in each serving the
really interesting thing is that if
you're like heat on a keto thing you can
eat magic spoon
and only 140 calories per serving it's
keto friendly gluten free grain free soy
free and low carb um
i don't know how they do it i guess
that's why they call it magic spoon
they're using some kind of like whey
product some milk product to make this
cereal and the flavor is just amazing
it's so good
it's super healthy it's packed with like
protein and uh no sugar and it just
tastes phenomenal it's really like
reliving the magic of your childhood
with the cereal
um
they got all kinds of flavors they've
got like the cocoa
the cocoa the fruity the frosted the
peanut butter i love the cocoa i'm a
sucker for the cocoa i love the frost i
love the fruity you know the fruity
loops come on dude i just i can slam
that [ __ ] and i feel great about it
um you can even mix them up mix and
match that's pretty interesting advice
i
love magic spoon since i tried it it's
filling up my pantry every day go to
magic just try it i'm telling you you're
gonna you're not gonna go back once you
try this
magicspoon.com
families grab yourself a variety pack
and try today and be sure to use our
promo code families
at checkout to save five dollars off
your order rumor has it with uh every
time you use the code families uh 10
butterflies are fine to milkweed
[Music]
and magic spoon is so confident in their
product it's backed by 100 happiness
guarantee so if you don't like it for
any reason they're going to refund your
money no questions asked and remember
grab your next delicious bowl of
guilt-free cereal at magicspoon.com
families and use the code families to
save five dollars thank you magic spoon
for sponsoring us
thank you to feels i'm feeling this cbd
isn't about what you feel it's about
what you don't feel
stress anxiety pain
i'm just gonna live off this thing i
have pain all the time
emotional pain does it fix emotional
pain
and feels is the best way to feel better
feels is a premium cbd that will help
keep your head clear and feel your best
it's hassle free delivered directly to
your door cbd naturally helps reduce
stress anxiety pain and sleeplessness
there's no hangover there's no addiction
you know you know cbd for those who
don't know it's the inactive ingredient
and uh
how do i say this without saying it the
green
blaze you know 420
uh it's the inactive part that's said to
give a calming effect but uh there's no
like you don't like get high from it
it's kind of just
i don't know it's a magic thing
apparently
so there's no hangover there's no
addiction it's just kind of a vibe
place a few drops of feels under your
tongue and feel the difference within
minutes wow there's uh the thing to
remember about cbd is that finding your
right dose is important and everyone's
dose is different in fact fields offers
a free cbd hotline to help guide your
personal experience so that you find the
perfect dose
the fields customer service team is
dedicated to make sure you get the best
use of your cbd and joining the fields
monthly membership makes your self-care
easy
you'll save money on every order and you
can pause or cancel it every time so
it's time to start feeling better with
fields become a member today by going to
feels.com families you're gonna get 50
off your first order with free shipping
that's f e a l s
feels.com
families to become a member and get
fifty percent off automatically taking
off your first order with free shipping
that's feels.com
families
after years of five print contracts and
getting ripped off by big wireless
providers if we've learned anything it's
that there's always a catch so when i
first heard about mint mobile and
they're offering premium wireless
services at just 15 a month i thought
what's the catch but after speaking with
them and using their service it all made
sense there isn't one
mint mobile secret sauce is that they're
the first company to sell wireless
service online only they're cutting out
the retail stores there's no crazy
overhead costs and that all gets passed
down to you in the form of mysterious
fees
it doesn't get passed down to you
instead mint just passes on sweet
savings directly to you now dan i know
you've been using mint mobile for that
juicy savings you went from like a
hundred dollars a month for fifteen
dollars a month with mint mobile that is
exactly right i was using one of the big
carriers uh which will remain nameless
the evil empire uh but uh and yeah they
were charging me about a hundred dollars
a month for a comparable plan on how to
make mobile i mean it's just as good as
as
uh any other
cell phone provider you could find and
75 a month that's a i mean that's a big
difference that pays for like all your
streaming services pretty much straight
up or and more
85 a month in savings 85 oh good math
ethan
listen for people looking at save extra
few extra savings every month mint
mobile offers premium wireless for just
15 a month all plants come with
unlimited talk and text high speed data
delivered on the nation's largest 5g
network you can use your own phone with
mint mobile plan and keep the same
number along with all your existing
contacts and if you're not 100 satisfied
mint mobile has you covered with their 7
day money back guarantee so switch to
mint mobile get that premium wireless
service and it just starts at 15 a month
so get your new wireless plan for just
15 a month and get the plant shipped to
your door for free go to mintmobile.com
families that's mint mobile dot com
slash families cut your wireless bill at
fifteen dollars a month at
mintmobile.com families
if you dread looking at your credit card
statement you're not alone debt can feel
crippling but upstart can help you on
your path to financial freedom upstart
is the fast and easy way to pay up your
debt with a personal loan all online
whether it's paying off credit cards
consolidating high interest debt or
funding personal expenses over half a
million people have used upstart to get
one fixed monthly payment upstart knows
you're more than just your credit score
and it's expanding access to affordable
credit and unlike other lenders upstart
considers your income and current
employment to find you a smarter rate
for your loan within five minute online
rate check you can see your rate up
front for loans between one thousand to
fifty thousand dollars you can receive
the funds as fast as one business day
after your loan is accepted
find out how upstart can lower your
monthly payments today when you go to
upstart.com
families that's upstart.com families and
don't forget to use our url to let them
know we sent you loan amounts will be
determined based on your credit income
and certain other information provided
in your loan application please
everybody go to upstart.com
families thank you thank you
welcome back to family's feuds one more
thing before we get to the game
this is a trending clip of billy eyelash
what was her name again mom nobody help
her billy eilish oh good
so billy eilish
um
tell me what you think about this clip
here going in let's just play it for
everybody and then react okay okay one
question each thank you so much oh okay
thank you it wasn't a question but thank
you i love you so much billy
okay
i love you too
so no reaction and she's been canceled
for this that's it that's it i mean it's
just a zoom call right it is a zoom call
i've had so many times where there's a
lag and things don't come out right and
i can't tell what's happening yeah she
might be waiting for a question can you
see the rest of it because at the end of
the video she's like that and i agree i
this was the clip this was what was
clipped and going viral that's not fair
dude someone totally edited this
i'm with you 100
people been going after billy eilish a
lot lately and like this is just a
continuation of the war against billy
eyelashes
i actually i i have been seeing it
because she started posting photos that
are more like
showing off her body well she recently
turned to 18 right so she's no she's 19.
19. oh thank you mom she is she's 19.
excellent she's just more comfortable
with her body now or before she felt
like she wanted to cover it
and so she's getting a lot of hate for
it and people are looking to hate her
now for something because they're upset
but i kind of follow you know i i like
her and i've always liked her style
before and as someone who's kind of shy
and doesn't like to show off their body
i related to her style before but seeing
her evolve
is really cool and i like it and i think
it's awesome for her and there's nothing
wrong with it i can't understand the
hate that she's getting for it now it's
it's insane yeah how dare she wear a
bathing suit
i mean she's showing cleavage and that's
what everyone does on a daily basis
right you know well i think she's been
accused of queer baiting
is what the problem is something else
okay do you want to explain you want to
explain mom
well she's she's actually she's actually
been an advocate for the broader queer
community but she has been accused of
of queer baiting that's you know like on
her last video lost cause
you know anyway um
do you have an opinion on the accusation
well
high level analysis
what is queerbaiting
well you know
this generation i must say has been like
exploring their sexuality more than i
ever remember
dad and i growing up based on what i
heard don't go there no i mean i mean
like you you know
dad and i are headers heterosexual but a
lot of not what i heard i'm just kidding
but a lot of young people are exploring
you know like like uh like girl you know
i keep a girl i kissed a girl and i and
i liked it you know that whole
that whole deal and um and people were
always doing it just she's just
exploring her sexuality behind doors
well i think what you're trying to say
is it's like hip i mean that's what
it is yeah i mean using like uh they're
using homosexuality as a way of being
hip maybe right i think so i mean she
reminds me a lot of madonna
you know her fans like to dress like her
they're wearing their hair like her
and you know when she came out with the
with i guess some of these videos a lot
of her fans were saying wait are you
coming out
and so there was there was that
and then um
you know she always portrays herself
like as a rebel i mean her first ep ep
was called don't smile at me
so that's you know she's she's kind of
you know a rebel that way
and uh one of the big dramas that was
going on was uh
uh she liked a a tweet that someone else
had put out
and the tweet was about
um
the person that made the tweet
uh accused her fans as being
embarrassing of their their lack of
knowledge about billy and also liking
things that were not even true so she
liked me she liked the tweets and she's
writing her fans she liked the tweet
that this girl had put out she actually
you know you like the like button
and what did she do how did she hit it
didn't give me that motion again
she hit the like button okay smash that
like button
exactly and um
i mean i guess she was a little upset
because she was accused of uh well
there's a controversy about her
boyfriend right her boy i don't know
much about that okay well yeah my mom
can brought the whole dog on bill yeah
she was she
is she a butterfly or something she did
a whole freaking write-up she allegedly
circulated photos of her boyfriend
matthew what is his name it's her
boyfriend's name is matthew he comes
forward
he's an actor and he's a writer
and allegedly she she was she circulates
she circulated photo videos of him
making racist and homophobic comments
was she circulated
photos she did circulate yeah it's old
stuff okay whatever yeah that's kind of
an important difference okay that is an
important detail videos were circulating
i guess she was at disneyland or
something like that
anyway so there was that and um
so now her fans are on yeah
during her merchandise
have to do with anything they were at
what about because that's where the the
video took place they were at disneyland
when these when he made these these
comments
i don't
so according to my mom
according to my mom they're at
disneyland and he's saying all these
racial obscenities no there was a video
billy posted it
i i don't know that she pasted it out it
taste she posted it all i know is there
were videos and i posted it
she corrected yeah there was a video
posted
of her boyfriend
making these comments and i think it
took place at disneyland for some reason
okay and then there's there and then
there's they're showing uh they're
showing
fans destroying her merch on social
media wow okay and also there's been a
backsplash because
a back is that a granite backsplash
i'm sorry i meant to stay back actually
people know where i get it from because
i do that [ __ ] all the time so it's just
it's good for people to see she she she
put a shout out it was on tick tock she
said hi to her israeli fans on tick tock
oh that didn't go over well and
um i guess she wanted them to know that
her happier happier-than-ever album was
coming out and so um
you know there was a lot of people that
are anti-zionists that were given her
even
yeah
which i say
uh you know really who's the who's
prejudice now that just kind of rubbed
me the wrong way
anyway you should be able to acknowledge
people that live in israel that's not a
political thing yeah i mean that's
outrageous that she can't say hi to my
fans in israel
by the way there's also palestinian
people that live in israel we don't know
who she's talking to she didn't say hi
to my jewish fans in israel exactly
exactly and also there's been headlines
you know
uh saying beware the pop princess and
romanticizing death
on her uh sophomore elf now this is a
really deep glamorizing mental illness
that's just
i'm not saying she did it i'm just
saying that's what they they were
criticizing her well supposedly there it
is for
but i would just like to say
this year
33 states have introduced more than 100
anti-trans bill so i don't think billy
eilis
possibly is boring her sexuality is a
big deal thank you mom that's what i
think how progressive
let's play the feuds already
i like billy i think she's just getting
she's just in this i feel like every
artist or our entertainer they go
through a phase where everybody loves
them and then lots of people hate them
it's like a counterculture thing and
then everything settles so she's in that
where everybody's it's cool to start
hating her face right and um you know
change i mean she can change she evolves
yeah it's like people say oh you sold
out which means
uh i liked you when you weren't popular
but now everyone's discovered you so you
haven't changed but you've sold out
because you're popular now right i mean
and all these things like i mean sure
there's there's room for small
criticisms here and there but guys this
is nothing made i mean the girl has
really not done anything that's what
madonna went through you know right
totally remember that
well
i mean she's that's a good analogy
though because i think it's creative and
people dressed like her they dress like
billy and they wear their hair with all
those fun colors any comment ela did you
did you want to add
no
all right let's get to the game
all right what about what about the
we'll probably skip that for today okay
yeah
all right all right the music one more
time please
all right
family skewed
today
you know how the game goes we've got sir
you guys all know how the game goes we
do you've got surveys and you have to
pick the top questions
two people come up
who wants to uh team captain so start
with me and you mom from the top okay
and then you know the winner gets to the
side to play or pass the board okay
play or pass play your pass
okay all right
survey says you've got all the answers
at the top you got to pick the most
popular answers to win
all right when that's important and
there's five answers that are possible
or six rounds on the first category
there's six top answers okay we asked a
hundred people
and this was their top answers go ahead
guys what is our first uh lightning
round question ready okay
okay name a part of the body
people see a plastic surgeon about just
kidding wait okay you believe this [ __ ]
okay you're gonna have to say it again
too early oh my god here you shouldn't
you should have to keep your hand like
here okay
okay ready go ahead okay name a part of
the body people see a plastic surgeon
about
who was first i couldn't tell
mom we're gonna need a judge on this any
we have a verdict on that one donna was
first okay go ahead mom wow
well in my day
you say one word
answer
we don't care about you you know what
knows
no survey says
yeah
no
okay so now good answer so now you need
to decide if you want to play or pass i
want to play okay
wait ethan don't you have to go
wait what you could still potentially
get the top answer oh if you have a
chance to oh oh really if i get the top
answer
who asked you back there i no i thought
the first person that chimes in oh if i
get the first answer
no who no i believe if you don't get the
top answer oh okay i guess so i know
what it is it's boobs
that is
correct
[Applause]
so now it would go ela's next right
yes yes okay so we can we can talk
amongst ourselves here so oh
you you oh can you do that we have to
fill in the rest yes okay so yeah
i would say
lips
i thought everybody had
had the only choice so so lips i didn't
know you could okay go ahead all right
we've have an answer here
lips lips lip survey says
legs
all right jessica oh that's easy
i know what the next one is so now we're
thinking
facelifts or
some does that count stomach like lipo
bugs butts butts these days butts is
good butts we like butt okay
all right we're gonna go with butts
survey says butts
i'm gonna come i'm gonna come here
all right so um
so uh what were we saying
facelift facelift okay all right we are
gonna go with facelift
survey
says whoa
okay we've got one left for a full clean
sweep here
um
i think
yeah i think
i know what it is
that's what i just said okay look go
ahead
all right don't say anything liposuction
that we will accept
[Applause]
now liposuction you you're thinking
belly is a tummy tuck
interesting thing but i believe you can
liposuction other parts of the body yeah
yeah yeah yeah you can liposuction
excuse me
the judges ruled in our favor
well i think the judges are incorrect
well you guys lost the first round hey
i'd like a judge that isn't paid by you
[Applause]
okay so okay so here give it to a dad so
this is dad versus ela now i'll just
hold the button
well here you
just put it on mom's legs okay yeah okay
all right hands hands equal distance not
so close
okay
name something for which kim kardashian
is famous for
oh that's
scary
but
large butt
survey says
how is that not number one yeah really
yeah that's what i love
how is butt not number one i would
figure like i mean literally that's fine
that's it was it that instagram picture
of her with a champagne glass and her
cheeks okay so oh i get to go i get to
go so
you think that's number one wait i don't
i'm not supposed to i'm not supposed to
solve it it's up to you yeah or elo only
has to have an answer okay that's right
yeah without having only okay
wow who's got the clock
all right um you have uh 15 seconds
starting now
[Music]
her porn video
survey says that is the top answer
i would never guess that that was
i didn't know that
you're playing the fame it's just like
that's how she became yeah well that's
true
that is true
well shout out to the family
16 higher pass
come on please play it we're going to
play it okay
yeah jess go ahead i'm thinking um
instagram the show
yeah or the show the show yeah okay uh
we're gonna say keeping up with the
kardashians
you guys wanna argue that one too no
okay that should be number one
no
all right
well she only got the show because of
her porn video you guys like instagram
oh like her marriage to kanye okay
all right we're gonna go with her
marriage to kanye west that is an
acceptable answer oh we got that hard
one we got we got that
instagram
she's like number one on the whole site
okay
instagram that is an acceptable answer
oh man
i think we're gonna need more boards you
guys
does she have some kind of product that
she uses skims
skins but social media her sisters her
sisters are famous
but that's kind of the reality i think
we gotta wrap it up we need an answer
maybe it's for boobs go ahead all right
i'm gonna i'm gonna go with boobs i'm
gonna say people are shallow
so sorry i'm a little stumped here
big-ass titties
it was like cosmetics
you didn't say that
it's pretty big okay
guys guys i'm gonna go with uh her
products
products oh [ __ ] down to two strikes
her sisters yeah
her family
[Applause]
that means i'm gonna save
money all right jess it's on you now
okay so how do we do this here john all
right i am not going to be bested here
um
shawn you can hold it in your own hand
so what about i hold it gary yeah yeah
okay all all right hands on your lap
hands on your on your lap like my sister
do like this okay my sister like i'm not
anybody i know it's just your sister
okay all right go ahead okay wait do we
have to wait till he finishes the
question yes
currently the score is ethan's team 151
donna zero yeah we know
so the question is if you heard your
bedroom door open as you may love who
would you really hope not to see when
you looked up
your children
[Music]
uh we're gonna say that team donna won
that one wow
winning but do they keep messing it up
all right okay get that number one
you guys can't help him totally hit that
faster where's that kind of like sorry
can you read the question one more time
wow
you can't ring the bell if you don't
know the answer to the question yeah
this is something yeah yeah yeah i agree
four three you're you're children or a
child
good answer good answer
come on
yay
i know all about that
pass
right right place
all right go ahead
so i believe that goes too all right
dude when the door opens all right play
the timer play some time you do not want
to see
the timer
okay are we can i say something yeah
you're ready your parents
okay okay good yeah
you guys are kind of getting screwed
because your number's already getting
small it's gonna get hard okay
who do you know
you gotta hit him with the timer here
keep the pressure you didn't get a timer
you got as much time as you wanted well
well yeah as we say not as we do
interesting
how long do they have one of your
siblings siblings
well i mean there's there's only some
there's a ton of options to maybe
hit him with a guest
a friend
yeah like if you're at the dorm room oh
oh wait i got a good one what
your spouse is
[Applause]
eight there's got to be okay all right
hit him with it
okay if your door's opening
yeah
your roommate yeah good answer good
answer
[Applause]
[Music]
one strike
hit him with that guys
[Music]
billy eilish oh gary come on
the serious show
your grandparents grandparents
all right we gotta get ready your dogs
your pets
what could it be
is our last one
that could be
no
in your house
neighbor
no in your house
wow why are they there
about how about friend
well i said
roommate friend first your friend show
us friend
oh no now it's our turn we get one
chance to steal
i think so
cause no one's gonna get all right okay
all right guys we've decided we are
going to go for the steal
with housekeepers
undefeated
[Laughter]
is over
[Music]
[Applause]
well that's true i made technically
i think i necessarily i don't
necessarily want them in my house at any
time during any act sexual or not but
that's a strange answer a serial wow
that was a tough one
no one would have gotten that well that
was a difficult one for sure
yeah we should have passed that one yeah
i think when you see eight it's a good
idea to pass because those are generally
pretty tough
because then you get the chance to steal
it like we did
all right up next is back to me and you
mom okay oh wait i don't need i don't
need them
all right all right this one's got seven
so mom here's the rule put your arm down
like this
okay ready
all right go ahead okay
we only asked married people by way i
mean me and dan what is the most
expensive thing you've ever bought you
he didn't finish
i
know what it is
how do you know well she buzzed in so
let let her give her a bump i think you
have to wait why yeah you don't have to
wait we already established the rules
because i asked earlier and they said
you have basically finished reading the
class
oh i am i'm extremely competitive
mr competitive i didn't realize my mom
was so competitive
i always play spit and win jesus you're
competing as your own granddaughter yeah
she's never won yeah oh yeah from the
start
i always win the game what is the most
expensive thing you've ever bought while
married without telling your spouse
first
that's right
that's basically to fight my whole child
[Laughter]
you know i hit that one first but you
guys be the judge okay
excuse me the judges are conferring back
the judges are confirmed i'm being told
donna got it
what is happening
okay
i'm gonna i know what i would say but
i'm gonna say clothing
clothing no yes the most expensive
survey says i mean there's seven it's
gotta be let's go
okay
girls can spend a lot of time okay so
now i get a chance to steal
i'm gonna wait wait what are you gonna
do yes
because she didn't get the top answer
yeah oh right i forgot did everybody
forget how to play this game but me yeah
dear thing king all right go ahead
all right
i'm gonna say
um
jewelry
survey says
nothing
wow
listen i have a healthy relationship we
don't go behind people's backs and buy
[ __ ] that is hard to believe wow okay
okay so you guys are stealing or playing
no wait
you guys really gonna pass to us wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
confirm first
no
i know what girls will spend money on
okay jewel maria okay
i would have done it all right go ahead
we're going to sweep it again
purse show us purse well isn't that part
of clothing let's find out
what
right okay all right let's talk let's
try yeah
wow this is oh
i suck at that
cars going out going out
going out
just a reminder this is for married
people not just women
going out
oh
you gotta be going out with your friends
i mean yeah maybe
i don't know a car
car that's a big buy to go behind your
back
yeah how can you do that behind you
don't help them it's got to be going out
does that just tick is there a timer or
just taking how is it all right what is
it 60 minutes yes you're right five
seconds
i need an answer five probably four
you're your turn
two okay so i would say going out with
friends
how hard this category is i think
did we get another one no they get 17
whopping points do i get to answer
yeah you as a team okay what was that
two no that was there's two you guys get
one more game you get one more strike
you get one more oh [ __ ] nice try so
wait now here pastor yeah it's ethan
oh my god it's gotta be caught
you think of people oh right you don't
need the mic either don't help okay
sorry no
okay i'm gonna just go i can't honestly
think of anything this is the hardest
category of all time i'm going to say
car
survey says the top answer is car
because i'm thinking what kind of
psychopath goes behind their spouses
back up by the car
psychopaths well how can you
i like how to ruin a marriage
if i came home with a new car honey it's
like what these are people that have
maids too remember that answer so was
this in beverly hills is that where this
is i know i didn't even think of may no
he's got a man what
vacation
i can't believe
that is an acceptable answer ah
who are they these people these people
are insane
you're going on a vacation without
telling yourself you're thinking about
women you gotta think about guys what do
you guys do
anyone for anyone to just bounce on
their spouse like and take a vacation
that's mental
this is like this is like what all right
marriages
build those points you have nine seconds
okay that's pay-per-view pornography
while on trip
i mean i really am so stumped on this
one
you really think that's on there
no really i mean
it's your it's yours okay i was kidding
but yeah i'm going to say hotel room
porn oh my god
good answer good answer all right so
they if it's out there
team donna just needs to get one to
steal right wait wait did we get it did
we hello
beeped okay i know what the answer is
thank you i know at the end okay four
answers actually okay
i know what a the next answer is okay i
can't wait do i get to answer it yeah
furniture
can i think are we still playing no
you're not show us number four i think
we both lose yes no that's fine we all
lose what i want to know what the hell
these answers are number four okay here
we go number four
tv
number
[Applause]
i think you guys may have noticed what
did you ask it's it's surprise a lot of
these are surprises i believe like
they're surprising that's why they
didn't tell them first
like right yeah
that's helping us a lot what maybe
someone should have explained that from
the beginning yeah and you're gonna have
to explain to me why jewelry isn't on
that list
because yeah because maybe the women
aren't actually fessing up to having
them buy some of that present nobody's
buying a boat we already lost no we
didn't oh there's there's no you lost so
now it's uh now it's the final feud
right or do we have more we have six
total so this is okay
[Applause]
all right so now i believe it is uh my
dad versus ela okay so we gotta we have
to regulate this hands-on hands on your
legs i'm going to put the belt here
i would like to make sure that there is
accurate camera footage
of the timing
yeah okay
dad both hands on your lip okay okay
ready go ahead
what might a married person rather admit
to their friends than to their spouse
oh that was really close
judges i think dad
this is tough i'm asking three judges
right now
they're reviewing the they're reviewing
the first i told you it was a bad idea
to do it with two bells it's like it's
impossible
what else
i think it was dad
judges are saying ela
all right the judges have ruled all
right
no helping during this time okay
um
cheating
yep that's a good answer good answer
what was the question again cheating
wait something what
okay wait what was the question
something you're more comfortable
talking to your friends to than your
spouse right wow how is tuning not your
head that was but it would have been my
answer too all right dad your chance to
take it
something you achieve wait wait wait
wait we need to make a correction it is
that is on there
how do you guys [ __ ] that up yeah really
cheating well that's a big one it's got
to be number one
how many other ones did you guys miss on
the previous
the wording is
curious
[Applause]
that's a good answer
you could emotionally achieve i don't
think that that's very generous the
judges weighed in yeah well then well
listen this is not unfortunate this is
not a debate
all right you guys get a chance to see
it
can you read the question again they
read it oh my god this isn't the
spelling bee
what might a married person rather admit
to their friends than to their spouse
yeah their weight
no maybe not
they're having sexual problems
oh oh
good answer oh good answer okay i hope
wow
well you know what these are young
viewers okay player pass i guess it's on
it's on oh yeah we have to play it wait
what how old were these people surveyed
that's a good question that is a good
question i think they're adults they're
like 18 plus they're adults yeah but is
it like 18 to 30 year olds or is it like
you're talking to the microphones okay
you're playing okay we're playing 18 to
100 year olds okay okay
i mean that's just not is that wow
what is something that you would not
want to
yeah that's it i'm gonna go with mine no
no no no no no
go ahead go ahead all right um work
problems
what
work problems
don't show us work problems
i will that's an acceptable answer yes
thank you survey says
so which one oh that's a well that's
that's pretty cool
thank you
okay i'm in the microphone yeah okay
you're doing great job
i think dance is going to be more likely
should i try jess go ahead it's kind of
connected which one is that i'm going to
say
sexual harassment
wow okay pretty heavy
i would think you would share that with
your spouse
all right five seconds need an answer
wait wait wait dieting wait
okay give me a second at least let me
stew in it that's right three all right
these are so hard okay so
all right
thank you
just so we would be sure all right come
on eight points let's go hold on with my
first answer guys it's not your turn
one more yes
yeah go for it addiction addiction
addiction
what is on this board
all right you guys i'm just stumped why
would you talk to your friend that's
already on there over here checking out
another hottie he already said that okay
he might be right
that's obvious okay wait read this read
the question one more time what might a
married person rather admit to their
friends than to their spouse
the word is admit
you want a divorce from your spouse
there's the debate no that's not it
there's debate nothing
what the f
all right i this is the hardest game
ever reveal the answer all right here we
go number one was
their spouse is a bad cook
number two strange
is that they don't like their spouse's
family number three
they don't like their spouse's friends
oh my god
uh number four
this is worded weird dirty picture slash
magazine i guess your porn preferences
yeah i guess your porn preferences is
what that means uh number five anyone
about that that they're in debt oh my
goodness and number eight
that their kid is ugly
that is not a real answer worst answer
is ever ugly
who are these people i don't want to
talk to my spouse that my kid is ugly
say what
the bad coke one makes a lot of sense
all right uh this is our last board here
number six here we go we got a lot of
catching up oh my god all right how are
we doing by the way okay
hands on your knees hands on your knees
okay get ready all right go ahead all
right stand by your knees here comes a b
with the final question on which topic
might a father give advice to his son
that's okay that was a clear winner
all right no advice why
it's easier to just
oh my god i'm gonna say i'm gonna go
general and just say the birds and the
bees first and the bees that is
acceptable birds and the bees
let's take it let's go with it yep all
right
all right my turn
let's go with shaving
yeah that's a good one
[Laughter]
right that's weird i would think that
that would be up you guys want to double
check the board on that one uh okay let
me double check it yep shaving isn't
there
okay
yep that's good yeah that's good
yes
yes
look at this it's that's definitely it
yeah she's right she's right
again please for a whopping
three
that's the hardest answer
that's good there you go
something a father teaches his son right
advice advice specifically advice advice
um
dating oh wait list
and five seconds okay so we're gonna go
with
a job or career that is number two
[Applause]
okay we're going to go with education
you you heard me
nobody would think of that it's not even
on the floor it's not even on there good
job mom
how many strikes is that that's true
[Music]
the second one yeah the first one
all right driving
for another whopping three points
all right build those points up
smash that like button
five seconds
let the judges confer for a second
because that's borderline oh if it's
borderline then forget it i i the judges
are saying too broad i'm sorry i'm
asking can you clarify
there you go
clarify a little bit more specific
within five seconds five four um like
chivalry morality
[Laughter]
all right
interesting okay
yeah i
you know how to fix things yeah yeah i i
think it's the father would give advice
on how to fix things mechanical things
good answer
if it's not
oh come on so sorry so sorry all right
just reveal it all right and at the
number three spot was money it got like
financial advice okay
uh number four was raising kids having
their own family and number five this is
the one that we had to confer on the
responsibility
drugs and alcohol oh
boy we really suck okay
[Laughter]
all right
for final family feuds i think the
respondents bear heavy responsibility
for us our trouncing here
did you know we lied you insulting the
sour grapes yes consulting the survey
these weren't very hard i actually got
to say that these were extremely
hard what about what about ones like
name a sport
yeah
yeah that's baseball yeah exactly number
one answer well we did win two boards i
think right off the bat total sweep yeah
you did so that means we're doing final
feud all right and so oh wait this
wasn't the final oh yeah
no now that we've won now we're playing
for the bonus points we got a bonus
round it's a big jackpot and each one of
these right is 500 right ethan so i have
a vested interest in throwing this
wait what
let's just do um
you know what would be probably the most
fun is like me versus my mom in the
bonus round or something because it's
just two people right
we'll take that
yeah it's like you picked two people
don't worry you're okay with this here's
how here's how it works
this is for two people only yeah it's
for two people
they ask what six questions i think so
how it works is i have like five seconds
to answer each one
and then
my mom comes out afterwards and tries to
answer after me but she can't repeat if
you repeat the same question you get a
buzz and you have to give another answer
you only have five seconds you can pass
if you don't know it and move on and
come back to it right and we have to get
120 points is that right guys
i'm here yes i'm hearing we have to
escort one of you guys out though okay
so you want to go first
what yeah i'll go or you know why don't
you go first
yeah why don't you go first you go first
here's the deal
if if me and mom get this and i'm gonna
try my best everybody
gets 500 bucks what do you mean if you
if we all right get this don't ask
questions we'll take it
yeah okay or not all right here we go so
are you ready donna i am all right dan
you ready
yes i am
okay all right uh so i'm gonna put 20
seconds on the clock and it is starting
30 seconds oh i'm sorry i'm gonna put 30
seconds on the clock and that 30 seconds
starts right now name things you would
post on social media
your vacations
what annoying things do dogs do
lick themselves name a winter sport
ski name something you always find two
of
shoes what do people usually take with
them to the beach
towels
okay you got it in 19 seconds
good answers
okay so name things you post on social
media you set a vacation for 24 points
what annoying things do dogs do you said
lick that is unfortunately zero points
name a winter sport you said ski that is
24 points
name something you always find two of
you said shoes for 24 points
what do you usually take with you to the
beach you said towel for 27 points for a
grand total of 99 points
big money big money big money
[Applause]
okay that's what dogs do
so we're going to move on to round two
let's get ethan back in here
so donna received 99 points so you need
21 points to win 99. wait 99 or 91.
99. no my god that's insane
how many out of how many points though
it could be 200.
no we need 120. you're on the same team
oh oh oh okay wow
all right
i'm ready for that beeper you must have
got a lot of number ones all right go
ahead
all right we're gonna do 30 seconds on
the clock stand by
ready and begin name things you would
post on social media
uh
uh bikini
what annoying things do dogs do
bark name a winter sport
winter sport skiing
your mother said skiing snowboarding
name something you always find two of
balls
what do you people usually take with
them to the beach
say that again what do people usually
take with them to the beach a towel
that's a monster umbrella
okay and that's 30 seconds right there
all right let us tabulate the score
people say a bathing suit i'm shaking
all right the judges have given me the
results okay
okay name things you would put on social
media ethan you said bikini photo the
answer
received zero
the top answer was a selfie it was one
selfie oh a selfie is there not like a
beach photo or a vacation or something
selfie in a bikini
yeah selfie okay
okay
okay uh what annoying things do dogs do
you said bark for 14 points
the top answer was p or poop on the
floor
i said lick themselves okay good answer
name a winter sport
ethan you said snowboarding for 21
points
the top answer was hockey hockey
yep for 30.
name something you always find two of
them
uh
ethan you said balls
that is uh zero points
shocking
what do people usually take with them
today
eyes eyes
okay what did mom say shoes
okay that's a good answer
what do people usually take with them to
the beach
uh you said umbrella for 23 points
your mom i answered towel which is the
top answer for 27 points yeah
so that is a grand total of 157 points
[Applause]
everyone's head is cut off everybody's
head has just been sliced off
there you go
there we go
thanks for watching family feud
everybody hey
[Applause]
legal reasons it's family's feud thank
you very much
thank you very much
now here everybody smooth here what just
we'll just roll credits and we'll just
be talking and schmoozing okay
you got to get low
you guys are still out of the frame
everybody everybody sit down
and
yeah we changed it but we won yeah